I think we're alone now isn't the song
from the AES it's in fact a 2018
post-apocalyptic science fiction story
starring Peter Dinklage
unlike most action films that use the
aesthetic of the World's End I think
we're alone now has a heart and human
story behind there that I think works
beautifully as an analogy of modern-day
issues throughout this video I'll be
discussing the ending of I think we're
alone now as well as the themes of the
film there will be heavy spoilers and I
definitely recommend that you give this
one a watch if you're looking for
something slightly different
without the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to I
think we're alone now centers around the
character of Dell and played by Peter
Dinklage after an undetermined
post-apocalyptic event wipes out the
majority of humanity Dell believes that
he is the last man on earth and lives
alone in a small town library after
being awakened one night by fireworks
Dell discovers grace and the two former
friendship eventually we learn that Dell
is indeed not the last man on earth and
there exists a community of 1,000 people
Dell was unaware of this because he
refused to leave his own little world to
visitors from the community searching
for grace informed Dell that there are
procedures that allow survivors to
forget their past traumas entirely and
that these are what have allowed the
human race to continue and thrive
stubborn as ever
Dell turns down Grace's invitation to
join the community and returns to a
solitary lifestyle now unable to live
alone though adult journeys out to find
Grace who has had some of the mind
modification procedures though we
eventually learn that it has not worked
the two then traveled to the community
where they discover all of the
population blissfully ignorant to what's
come before shunning this Dell and grace
decide to return to their own little
town where they can live together with
one another which ends the film
obviously there's a lot to unpack from
this and to me the clearest analogy that
can be drawn from it is the immigration
crisis that is rampant in modern
politics Dell walling himself off from
the world can be viewed as symbolism for
the current US government's plan
to build a physical wall between the
border of their country and Mexico del
has forgotten how much diversity and
different demographics have positively
impacted his life
and he now lives in a little bubble
refusing to venture outside of it which
leaves him trapped from people on the
outside who currently lived the happy
and carefree life that he is quietly
desperate for the fireworks that
awakened him could be viewed as a
metaphor for the fireworks that are set
off on the 4th of July when America
celebrates their independence this is to
remember the period when the country
joined the rest of the world as its own
entity America was once a country that
was welcoming to all from around the
world however it slowly begun to
strengthen its borders and retreat to
its comfort zone much in the same way
that Dale and grace do at the film's
close however this isn't some
idealization of the rest of the world
and I'm certainly not trying to paint
our America in an ignorant white
juxtaposing their plight the cult to
make promises of escaping one's past and
being perfect and the film beautifully
showcases that there is no true utopia
other than the one that we make for
ourselves things like the pretend
parents tracking down grace due to a
scar on her neck which clearly contains
a tracking device informs the audience
that not everything that glitters is
gold and there are people on both sides
that will twist the truth to get what
they want it's a beautifully complex
film and I definitely recommend that you
watch it obviously a lot of this is my
own personal opinion so if you agree or
disagree then I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of the ending of
Suspiria which is linked at the end of
this video this is a channel for people
who are mad about movies soap that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]